or y en a qui a été plus ému que les
autres puisque l'un qui n'a pas eu son
cadeau cgil qu'est ce qui se passe ou
non rien non plus sur la phrase de
maxime
bah oui bah il a eu raison il y avait
beaucoup d'émotion de si vous n'aimez
pas père noël s'il vous plaît ne vous
aime pas les autres j'en ai un petit peu
ras la hotte de n'y a que vous qui avez
pas eu de cadeau et vous avez vécu un
moment d'émotion exceptionnel incroyable
un des plus beaux moments de votre vie
j'arrive pas encore à m'en remettre à y
croire c'est flou il va falloir
commencer à s'en remettre ce qu'on a
repris boulot j'ai une bougie
c'était quoi tout c'était un pour moi
rien et photos des beaux cadeaux carmel
m
alors gilles
pour toi rien je te confirme et pour
fatou sage qu'aujourd'hui elle est à
paris
et que fatou grâce à coiffe à paris et
heureuse
puisque fatou
a eu beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup de
cadeaux tu vas le voir dans une vidéo
que je vais travailler tout de suite
vous avez dit tout pour fatou ça nous a
émus vous allez me faire pleurer et on a
fait passer une journée de rêve afin que
je vais chercher un petit écran tu vas
voir tout ce qui s'est passé pour fêter
aujourd'hui et gilles j'espère que tu
seras heureux de voir celle que tu aimes
heureuse je t'amène la vidéo j
[Applaudissements]
on ne sait pas plus
comment vous savez fou mais je t'ai
appelé aujourd'hui tu dois parler
oh
je sais vous dans la peau nue dans le
flanc
[Applaudissements]
on a fait le trou il avait chanté je
suis avant tout les caisses que je suis
heureux
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et à l'italie est il encore ému mabrouk
ali kaïs haye et mabrouk gras comme on
dit chez nous c'est vrai franchement là
c'est un des plus beaux de vivre c'est
incroyable parce que j'ai du mal à
parler mais en fait c'était impossible
qu'elle soit là je l'aï bien impossible
n'est pas bavard mais justement c'est
vous alma raconté après c'est vous qui
l'avez appelé personnellement alors
c'est jeu l'a appelé personnellement et
ella ella salon d'esthétique oui j'ai dû
trouver quelqu'un qui la remplace mais
oui oui pas vrai pour le week-end de
noël
j'ai appelé vous connaissez le monde y
est j'ai appelé tout le monde de laisser
tout le monde s y est d'ailleurs je
remercie a besoin tout site web et vous
à idées et qui a trouvé quelqu'un de
formidable bravo et j'aurai mon départ
n'est jamais parce qu'en plus je les
appelais est là elle a été super louis
je les appelais elma elle m'a raconté
qu'elle était à paris tous à jamais leur
accrue c'est incroyable qu'ils les tours
laponie je suis je n'arrive pas à parler
tellement je suis encore email c'est un
tour de force incroyable
vous avez passé après la soirée avec
fatou oui absolument y en avait un cas
kane qui peut raconter c'est bien vous
dire il n'ya pas un beau moment
d'émotion sympa
j'entame sortie c'est de bons moments à
partager
j'étais si jeune